[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est pas les
au dews l'émission qui fait des news
avec du vieux alors aujourd'hui on va
rattraper les news de l'été juillet août
et septembre parce qu'on est déjà en
octobre en tout cas un moment où sort
cette vidéo on sera pas loin d'octobre
du tout donc on va rattraper aussi les
news de septembre et on va avoir donc du
pain sur la planche parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont sortis et on
commence avec les premières preuves
fossiles de la présence d'êtres humains
en amérique du nord avant quinze mille
ans alors il faut savoir que les êtres
humains à sont censés avoir migré en
amérique du nord il y a quinze mille ans
à la faveur justement de
l'a22 delà de la proche d'un maximum
glaciaire qui a réussi à former un pont
de glace
entre le entre l'asie et l'amérique et
donc ça c'était la théorie tel qu'on
l'avait admise telle qu'on l'admette ou
jours encore aujourd'hui voilà l'arrivée
des êtres humains en amérique du nord il
ya quinze mille ans il y avait eu des
découvertes que j'avais commenté par le
passé qui suggérait qu'il y avait des
êtres humains avant ça en amérique du
nord notamment y avait eu des outils qui
avaient été découverts d'à peu près 24
mille ans il y avait des traces de
découpe qui avaient été découverts
jusqu'à il y à cent mille ans
donc ça ça repousserait quand même
l'origine des êtres humains en amérique
du nord très très loin dans ce cas là
mais bon on a on a plusieurs formes de
preuves indirectes qui s'étaient
accumulées on va dire pour dire qu'il y
avait des êtres humains en amérique du
nord avant quinze mille ans mais il
manquait les êtres humains
il manquait les fossiles d'êtres humains
qu elle veut dire c'est quand même le la
base si vous voulez du truc et bien ça y
est un article qui vient de sortir dans
la revue alors ça doit être ça yann ce
si je ne me trompe pas c'est ça un
article de ressorti dans la revue
prestigieuse signs voilà vous montre ses
magnifiques fossiles d'êtres humains
regardez comme c'est beau le jeudi il
n'y a pas de place il n'y a pas de marge
dans l'interprétation de ces empreintes
de pas voilà ça c'est
ccbbo quoi à ce niveau à ses limites on
se demande si elles n'ont pas été si
elles n'ont pas été creusés
artificiellement tellement elles sont
belles quoi c'est vraiment de très très
belles empreintes de pas qui ont été
retrouvés dans le nouveau mexique et qui
ont été datés enfin c'est un ancien
dépôt lacustre vous voyez c'est un très
très bel exemple de calcaire lacustre
que vous voyez là très très blanc très
très très joli et donc c'est un ancien
dépôt lacustre donc d'un lac le fond
d'un lac peu profonds et en fait il ya
des graines qui se sont fossilisés dans
ce lac est ce qui fait qu ils ont réussi
à dater en fait chaque chaque couche qui
s'était posé dans le lac c'est ce que
vous voyez sur cette colonne
stratigraphique a pu être datés gràce
aux graines non pas non pas par
corrélation bio stratigraphique mais par
tout simplement carbone 14 puisque les
graines contiennent du carbone ce sont
des anciens organismes vivants donc ils
ont daté le carbone 14 contenues dans
ces graines et ça leur a donné vous
voyez dh qui vont de 22000 à 21 millions
déposés dans un ordre parfait ordre
chronologique parfait donc les dates se
vérifie les unes par rapport aux autres
c'est magnifique ça marche très bien
donc entre 23 et 21 mille ans on a des
empreintes de pas humain qui montre que
donc il y avait des humains avant quinze
mille ans en amérique du nord donc
maintenant ça y est la c c'est plié faut
réviser nos
faut réviser nos livres d'histoire faut
réviser nos cours d'archéologie parce
que ben voilà les êtres humains sont
arrivés avant le dernier maximum
glaciaire en amérique du nord et alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que du coup
ils ont cohabité avec la mégafaune
n'avait pas ce que la mégafaune elle
commence à s'éteindre à partir de onze
mille ans donc arriver des humains 15000
en début d extinction de la mégafaune à
eau à 11 mille ans la corrélation était
quand même assez évidente on avait envie
de dire que les êtres humains étaient
probablement la cause de l'extinction de
cette mégafaune bas là pour le coup on a
un exemple de cohabitation sur 3000 ans
quasiment trois mille ans
deux mille ans plus tôt deux mille ans
de la mégafaune avec les êtres humains
puisqu'on a des empreintes de pas de
mastodontes
préservé avec les empreintes de pas
humaine on a même des empreintes de pas
du fameux canis des russes le d'ailleurs
wolf le fan au chien géant de rendre
show la brea bas on a aussi des
empreintes de pas de ce truc là c'est
pas la peine de commencer à me sortir
qu'ils ont domestiqué les les chiens de
l'est les calices virus c'est
probablement pas le cas mais mais voilà
c'est en tout cas on a une preuve qu'ils
ont cohabité avec la mégafaune et
maintenant donc avec une extinction onze
mille ans et une arrivée des êtres
humains à au moins 23 mille ans eh ben
eh bien on a de bonnes raisons de penser
qu' il ya eu comme qui dirait
cohabitation très très longue avant le
début de l'extraction donc pas forcément
un lien de causalité entre l'extinction
et l'arrivée des êtres humains donc ça
c'est une découverte très très très
intéressante et là pour le coup c'est
clairement un truc qui réécrit une bonne
page de nos livres de préhistoire
on continue avec néandertal donc
maintenant on bouge en europe on quitte
l'amérique et on arrive en europe et en
europe donc j'ai décidé de vous montrer
cet article qui est sorti en qui est
sorti en juin 2021 et qui donc il ya un
petit peu en dehors de l'été j'ai envie
de dire mais j'étais passé à côté mais
il ya beaucoup de gens en fait qui m'ont
posé la question est-ce que néandertal
pose est est-ce que néandertal
faisait des peintures des peintures
rupestres je sais pas pourquoi la seul
coup tout le monde s'est bien posé cette
question cet été donc je voulais vous
montrer cet article tout à fait récent
qui parle justement est bien de
stalactites qui ont été peintes par des
néandertaliens et comment on sait
qu'elles ont été peintes par denner
berjalliens bas tout simplement parce
qu'elles ont été trouvés en espagne et
qu elles sont vieilles
qu'elles sont vieilles de à peu près 50
mille ans il ma mémoire est exact voilà
mais ici les dates ici entre 40 et 60
mille ans donc entre 40 et 60 mille ans
n'y a rien d'autre que néandertal en
espagne donc il ya que néandertal qui a
pu peindre c'est stalactites donc oui
les néandertal faisait des peintures
pariétales
avec toutes les implications que cela a
sur la pensée la possible pensée
symbolique donc voilà c'était juste pour
vous montrer cet article encore récent
donc il ya de la recherche qui se
développe autour de l'art pariétal
néandertaliens mais maintenant c'est un
fait qui est quand même assez bien
établi que néandertal peignait même si
c'était pas des on est bien d'accord
qu'on n'est pas l'équivalent de lascaux
c'est juste un peu d'offres sur des
stalactites 1
c'est pas lascony cosquer nippon barque
ça c'est sûr mais voilà néanderthal
avait quand même une certaine pensée
artistique qu'il faut reconnaître et
dont il faut tenir compte
on continue à pousser la limite
temporelle et à s'éloigner d'homo
sapiens maintenant on est admissible
manman ici en géorgie dans un article
qui est sorti dans scientific report
donc une succursale de nature's et bien
cet article de scientifiques report nous
parle des homo erectus ou aux monnaies
géorgie tus comme des fois on l'appelle
le l'homo erectus asiatiques
qui cohabitait avec des canidés et alors
c'est pas une découverte spécialement
hyper intéressante et c'est en fait ce
que je voulais vous montrer avec ça
c'est le sas a été vendu cet article là
qui nous fait qu'il ne fait que nous
parler d'une possible cohabitation entre
canidés et hominidés
il y à 1,8 million d'années
quelle idée qui n'est même pas
d'ailleurs directement le chien qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui je veux dire c'est
qu'à nice sous genres des notions donc
c'est pas du tout et licka l'espèce
celica no id est donc on est loin du
canis lupus 1 on est très très loin
encore du canis lupus
et pour une raison que j'ignore cet
article là a été vendu par la presse
comme la première preuve de
domestication à 1,8 million d'années
donc si vous avez vu passer dans la
presse un truc qui disait la première
preuve de domestication
chez homo erectus ça vient de cet
article là et c'est pas du tout ça que
ça raconte voilà c'est donc je tenais
quand même à vous en parler parce que ça
a été survendue dans la presse comme une
preuve de domestication non c'est juste
on a de l'hominidé et du canis aghmani
si il y à 1,8 million d'années ils ont
vécu ensemble et voilà et le truc c'est
que c'est vraiment un et là pour le coup
l'article vend vraiment ça comme une
possible comme impossible prémices à la
domestication ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est on a juste une concurrence de
cannes nice et deux homos c'est tout je
veux dire c'est comme si c'est comme si
à chaque fois qu'on trouvait un primate
c'était une preuve de 2,2 à chaque fois
qu'on trouvait un primate est un et un
canidé dans le registre fossile c'était
une preuve de domestication je le vire
non c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
donc je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
d'ailleurs je ne comprends même pas
comment ça a été publié dans un truc
aussi
aussi haut que c'est quand même une
succursale de nature scientifique report
c'est juste ça rapporte juste lac
occurrences d'un chien avec un homo
représentants du genre homo c'est tout
c'est même pas un chien d'ailleurs comme
je le disais c'est même pas canis lupus
et cani sous-genre des notions les
canaux -dès donc je
ça m'échappe un peu et ça a vraiment été
survendus et vous allez voir que là
pendant l'été il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été survendus voyez il ya les
cinémas essaie de nous vendre des
blockbusters mais la presse essaye aussi
de novembre des blockbusters
d'ailleurs dans la catégorie toujours
dans scientific report on a eu donc cet
article qui nous parle d'un impact
similaire à la météorite de tulum
tunguska qui a détruit une ville
de l'âge de bronze en jordanie donc
c'est une ville c'était à peu près il ya
3600 en fait il y avait une ville de
l'âge du bronze quelque part en jordanie
et donc ils ont retrouvé
voyez la localité et l'a1 est donc ce
qu'ils ont trouvé là dedans c'est
évidemment est un site archéologique qui
était déjà connu depuis très longtemps a
envoyé un palais un temple il y avait
quand même c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez bien organisés voyez ici
une reconstruction des bâtiments et tout
ça donc c'est un site archéologique qui
est connu depuis très longtemps 1 le
dialogue qui date de trois mille 3620
donc on est dans l'enclos l'antiquité
bien bien bien bien
bien profonde on va dire c'est la
vieille antiquités est en fait dans ce
site antique et bien il y à un dépôt un
dépôt qui contient tous les signes
typiques en fait de la chute d'une
météorite
on a notamment je vais vous montrer les
quartz choqué c'est ça que je cherche en
ce moment là on allait laisser férule
aussi les coincer choqué choc quartz
donc l'écho est choqué et ici vous êtes
familier de des études sur l'impact de
chips de lucky à
qui a participé à l'extinction des
dinosaures bas vous connaissez
l'histoire des quartz choqué ce sont les
quartz qui ont été déformés par l'impact
de la météorite les quartz normalement
c'est quelque chose de très dur un
quartz donc ça se déforme pas comme ça
un quartz donc il faut un métamorphisme
de très haute pression pour déformer à
quartz vous avez quoi choquer un peu
plus loin il me semble il nous montre
aussi des
détectives c'est à dire des
férule
des sphérules qui ont été formés d'eads
espère une de silice qui ont été formés
par les par l'impact donc il ya vraiment
tous les indices qu'un impact en fait
est venue frapper cette ville est
apparemment bas après après ça la ville
a été complètement abandonné donc c'est
ce serait un des rares exemples de
vraies villes vraiment de 2,2 vrai
espace
urbain aménagé par l'homme qui ont été
détruits par un impact de météorite dont
qui aurait celui là et puis dans là il
me semble qu'il parle aussi d'un autre
endroit qui se trouve en syrie
donc bref il ya deux il ya que deux
endroits apparemment où il ya eu des
assemblages robin qui ont été détruits
par des météorites et donc là c'est le
deuxième finalement qui nous est
présenté ici et avec des preuves qui
sont je trouve relativement convaincante
et alors là où ça a été survendue c'est
qu'en fait il ya une toute petite ligne
à la fin de l'article où il nous parle
de sodome et gomorrhe mais bref il nous
parle juste à la fin donc de sodome et
gomorrhe et de la possibilité en fait
que cette l'histoire de cet impact
météoritique est été transmis oralement
jusqu'à atterrir dans un certains
bouquins qui s'appelle la bible
donc et là où ça a été survendue c'est
que en gros les balais la presse a
présenté sa comme la preuve maintenant
que conte avec eux que ce dom et
gomorrhe avait été détruite par une
météorite non non c'est pas ça du tout
je veux dire ce qu'ils disent c'est que
possiblement
étant donné qu'on est à trois mille six
cents ans donc 1500 en avant avant notre
ère enfin mille six cent cinquante ans
comme ils disent ici avant notre ère il
est possible que le récit de cette de
cet impact météoritique qui a détruit
une ville entière ait pu être transmis
oralement de telle façon qu'ils
finissent par atterrir dans un certains
bouquins qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
bible voilà sous l'histoire possible de
sodome et gomorrhe mais je veux dire si
vous allez sur la page wikipedia de
sodome et gomorrhe vous verrez que c'est
pas la seule théorie qu'on a loin de là
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de théories qui
ont été proposées pour scientifiquement
expliqué le récit de sodome et gomorrhe
donc bref ça a été un peu survendu alors
que c'est ça a pas besoin d'être
survendu je veux dire c'est une [ __ ]
de ville qui a été rasée par une
météorite
pourquoi vous avez besoin de survendre
ça bref je veux dire c'est une ville qui
a été rasée par une météorite s'est déjà
rien que ça c'est m c'est énorme que le
dire comme u2 bref
on continue dans l'archéologie en reste
aux alentours de 3000 ans et alors là
c'est juste une curiosité mais moi ça
m'a ça m'a interpellé une curiosité qui
a été décrite dans journal of
archaeological science qui est sorti
tout récemment il est sorti en juin
aussi de 2000 t1 et alors c'est un
squelette qui a été découvert au japon
et ce squelette en fait il est
complètement constellé de morsures de
requins voyez chaque point rouge sur le
squelette c'est une morsure de requin
donc en fait ils ont ils ont fait
l'hypothèse qu'il s'agissait du corps
d'un possible pêcheurs qui avaient été
consommés par un requin vous voyez qu'il
manque une main et une jambe et un pied
donc il n'en manque pas mal de morceaux
quand même qu'ils ont possiblement été
consommée par un requin et donc ils ont
fait une étude assez complète de toutes
les morsures qui se trouve sur le
squelette et qui en a beaucoup beaucoup
donc c'est vraiment un squelette c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est une pauvre
personne qui s'est vraiment fait
consommer de a à z par un requin voyez
qu avec toutes les morsures qu'il a
reçus
il ya vraiment que beaucoup de morceaux
qui sont partis
donc voilà c'est juste une curiosité
voilà ça nous apprend pas grand chose
sur sur ce qui se passait auparavant
mais c'est juste une curiosité mais que
je trouve très intéressante
de par sa propre île de part son
existence en fait hein c'est juste c'est
juste ça on reste dans les morsures mais
cette fois on bouge vers les dinosaures
et notamment les preuves les dinosaures
préféré de tout le monde j'ai nommé les
tirades ouzou rider les tyrannosauridés
donc qu'ils sont très connus pour se
vendre la figure les uns les autres du
mois c'est une hypothèse qui avait été
formulé plusieurs fois au moins depuis
1998 et vous avez certainement vu sa
passe et dans pas mal de reportage mais
c'est vrai qu'il y avait jamais eu
vraiment d'études systématique de toutes
les traces de morsures qu'on a pu
retrouver
sur les crânes de tyrannosauridés est
donc là il ya eu une étude systématique
de ces morsures dont vous voyez quelques
exemples la s'afficher à l'écran et
cette étude systématique a quand même
trouvé pas moins de da peu près 500
occurrence quand même pardon 300
occurrence vous voyez là 209 ici et 114
là donc ça fait à peu près 300
occurrence de
de morsures faciale sur la sur la tête
des tyrannosaures et vous voyez quels
sont s anciennement distribuées sur le
museau alors il ya très très peu dedans
en font c'est qu'ils ont été retrouvées
donc la plupart du temps on fait
l'hypothèse que ce sont les
tyrannosauridés qui ont mordu mais en
réalité il ya qu' un ou deux cas où en
réalité on a retrouvé une dent et que
cette dent nous permet de dire ok ça
c'était définitivement une dame
tyrannosauridés donc bref c'est
évidemment on fait l'hypothèse que ces
morsures était faite par des
tyrannosauridés sur d'autres
tyrannosauridés mais on est bien
d'accord que de toute façon apparente
surtout chez tyrannosaurus rex mais
généralement les tyrannosauridés étant
complètement au sommet de leur chaîne
alimentaire un parent à notre
tyrannosauridés il n'y a pas grand-chose
qui s'aventureraient à mordre un autre
tyrannosaure
on est bien d'accord que ça reste une
hypothèse quand même assez raisonnable
et dans la mesure où s'est surtout
concentré sur le museau bas on a quand
même on a quand même
la trace que c'est des attaques qui sont
pas faites pour être mortelle
c'est dès attaques qui sont faites pour
basse et c'est exactement ce que font
les animaux moderne en fait quand ils
disent quand ils quand ils veulent
montrer leur domination quoi c'est ce
sont des attaques sociales voilà attaqué
le museau ça fait pisser le sang mais ça
fait pas ça tue personne voilà le musée
le musée ya rien de d'extrêmement vital
dans un museau qui vous tuera donc c'est
vraiment un message social
essentiellement et voyez qu'il ya
beaucoup de traces notamment sur les
mandibules donc les mandibules séparé il
ya une très très bonne présentation qui
a qui accompagne cet article fait ma
pensée dans les commentaires à la m si
j'oublie et très bonne présentation il
ya une des diapos qui montre les
crocodiles moderne des crocodiles
moderne qui se sont fait attaquer par
d'autres crocodile et on voit il leur
manque des deux me mâchoire et leur
banque la moitié du museau il leur
manque plein de morceaux parce que c'est
pareil les crocodiles il s'attaque ils
se mordent le museau les uns les autres
mais c'est assez facile entre guillemets
de survivre en ayant à mu ont endommagé
au final donc surtout quand on a les
mâchoires d'une puissance pareil comme
or donc voilà et donc il arrive même à
reconstruire la direction en fait des
morsures et la direction des morsures
c'est pareil on voit bien que les
morsures n'était pas dirigée pour tuer
elle était dirigée vraiment pour pour
faire du mal voilà pour endommagé mais
pas tellement pour tuer quoi donc c'est
très intéressant comme article et ça
démontre une bonne fois pour toutes que
le que les que les tyrannosauridés
s'attaquer
s'attaquer mais en tant que c'était du
du signalement sociale voilà il
s'attaquer mutuellement mais un sous
forme de signalement sociale donc là
c'est ce qu'on voit chez les crocodiles
et là où c'est intéressant aussi c'est
que ils ont regardé les crocodiles et
donc chez les crocodiles chez les bébés
crocodiles on n'a pas de morsures sur le
museau et d'un seul coup arriver à la
maturité sexuelle pouf le nombre de
morsures sur le museau crève le plafond
donc c'est ce qui est représentée ici
est ce qu'il ya un intéressant et ben
c'est que chez les tyrannosaures c'est
pareil c'est à dire que chez les bébés
tyrannosaure on n'a pas de trace de
morsures chez les ch et les
tyrannosaures
d'une taille de crâne particulière d'une
taille de crâne relativement petit on
n'a pas de trace de morsure et d'un seul
coup quand ils deviennent plus grands on
a vraiment une ligne sèche de deux
tailles de crâne à partir de laquelle
barn on a des morsures et donc ça cette
taille de crâne ce serait la taille qui
correspond à la maturité sexuelle donc
c'est pareil ça ça permet aussi du coup
c'est ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que ça veut dire qu'en gros maintenant
quand on retrouve un crâne de
tyrannosaures et qu'on trouve des traces
de morsures dessus on peut être à peu
près sûr que ce que ce crâne appartient
à un tyrannosaure sexuellement mature
apparemment ils trouvent pas de
différence entre mâles et femelles ce
qui est très intéressant enfin pas chez
les tyrannosaures mais ce que je veux
dire chez les
ch et les espèces modernes apparemment
ils trouvent pas de différence
entre mâles et femelles au niveau des
comportements de morsures c'est à dire
que c'est les deux sexes qui se mordent
la tronche voilà globalement
essentiellement les mâles mais les deux
sexes le fond voilà c'est
essentiellement les mâles qui se mord
d'entre eux pour évidemment pour la
domination sexuelle conquérir des
femelles
écraser ses ennemis les voir mourir
devant soi etc et mais le mais on
retrouve aussi des morsures chez les
femelles puisque les mâles évidemment se
bat aussi contre les femelles les
femelles entre elles se battent pour des
territoires des territoires de chasse
donc
donc il n'ya pas de différence mâle
femelle évidente par contre là où ça
devient encore plus intéressant c'est
que quand ils ont fait donc ils ont
passé en revue toutes les morsures qu'on
retrouve chez tous les théropodes et là
où c'est très intéressant c'est qu'on
retrouve ces morsures essentiellement
chez les grands théropodes
non tara vient donc les paras bien les
paras bien bas ce sont les dinosaures
shetty les plumes se sont développées
non pas que les autres théropodes
n'avait pas de plumes on sait que les
autres théropodes n'avait pas de plus
avec des plumes notamment chez les
tyrannosaures aux ide donc mais par
contre les dinosaures chez qui les
plumes sont vraiment devenus un apparat
visible et significatif on va dire en
termes de masse corporelle la quantité
de plumes devenait assez importante et
binche et ses dinosaures là ya pas de
trace de morsure est évidente et donc ça
renforce l'hypothèse comme je le disais
du signalement sociale c'est à dire que
le signalement social est passé d'un
signalement social de type crocodiliens
avec des morsures faciale et et vas-y
que je te montre ma grande gueule et
vas-y que je te mords situé pas
impressionner par ma grande gueule et ce
signalement sociale il est passé chez
les paras vient un signalement social de
type oiseaux à savoir un signalement
social par la démonstration d'un grand
plumage regarde comme je suis énorme
regarde comme je suis costaud voilà donc
ça c'est très très très intéressant et
là pour le coup c'est ce sont des traces
fossiles ce qui veut dire que ce sont
des choses qui se sont fait du vivant
des actes donc ça nous montre comment
les animaux vivaient et ça c'est beau
ça c'est beau donc voilà on a alors
c'est même pas que les paras vient
d'ailleurs parce qu'apparemment ils
n'ont pas non plus de trace de morsures
chez les combes soldati des donc vous
voyez que
que les paras vient normalement je crois
que ça inclut les objets rapt en rien ou
peut-être que les drom et aux orres avec
les bref vous voyez que tous les
dinosaures les plus dérive est là et les
petits notamment chez chez les petits
les combes soldati des ornithologues aux
orgues dont terry dinosaures c'est un
peu l'exception ils sont
fins et les plus gros terry dinosaures
qui sont connues mais ça veut pas dire
que tous les tirs et dinosaures étaient
gros c'est pareil pour les autres
acteurs aux offres les plus connus sont
les plus gros mais ça veut pas dire
qu'ils étaient tous gros mais en gros
dés que dès qu'on a le développement
d'un plumage vraiment très apparent en
fait les morsures faciale disparaissent
du registre fossile et ça ça montre bien
que les morsures fascinant que le
plumage à remplacer les morsures faciale
dans le signalement sociale
et c'est beau c'est beau comme étude ces
bouts comme hypothèse c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique donc là on a vraiment
le shift de comportement depuis un
comportement crocodiliens vers un
comportement a bien enregistré dans le
registre fossile des morsures faciale
on reste avec les tyrannosauridés nos
préférés alors là c'est pareil dans la
survente ça a été le plus beau je pense
qu'on a la palme de la survente dans la
presse
l'étude dont je vais vous parler
maintenant vous en avez probablement
entendu parler
selon cette formulation qui est un
nouveau dinosaure carnivore détrône le
t-rex ou bien à dinosaures un nouveau
dinosaure carnivore plus gros que le
t-rex ou je sais pas quoi un truc plus
gros que le t-rex ou plus redoutable que
le t-rex vous avez entendu parler de ça
vous en avez forcément entendu parler ça
fait tout le tour pendant tout l'été
c'était insupportable
parce que c'est complètement mais
complètement à côté de la plaque
voilà donc cet article donc tout ça
vient de cet article enfin est inspiré
de cet article parce qu'en réalité il
n'ya rien du tout qui vient de cet
article
mais tout ça est inspiré de la
communication qui a eu autour de cet
article et cet article eh bien il fait
que nous décrire un nouveau dinosaure
carcharodontosaures idée donc où nos
bases aux russes ou lebègue zaurus ça
vient de hulu baic qui était un roi
mongol si je ne m'abuse enfin cannes
mongol que vous connaissez certainement
si vous suivez la chaîne héros d'autres
comme parce qu'il en parle très souvent
et c'est un petit bout de mâchoire voilà
ça à séoul bugs aux russes voilà c'est
un morceau de mâchoire de
carcharodontosaures idée il ya largement
de quoi reconnaître que c'est un
carcharodontosaures donc on va pas dire
que va pas commencer à à se plaindre du
fait que assez juste un tout petit bout
de mâchoire de rien du tout donc y'a de
quoi reconnaître que c'est un
carcharodontosaures
par contre ça n'a rien à voir avec
tyrannosaure je veux dire ça aux
nouvelles exo russie vivaient au
turonien c'est écrit là voilà c'est la
cedh 1 dans cette phrase là il parle du
turonien donc lé tyrannosaurus rex il
n'a pas vécu au turonien il a vécu après
ça essentiellement aux maastricht ya
donc donc où le bateau russe n'a jamais
rencontré de tyrannosaurus et même pas
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs tyrannosaurus
sénat américain et lubero russe il est
asiatique donc donc non seulement il n'a
jamais rencontré de tyrannosaurus mais
en plus ils n'étaient pas plus gros que
tyrannosaurus mais genre du tout
absolument pas vous le dire vous
regardez la taille du machin voyez ça ça
fait 5 cm voilà vingt centimètres là
dessus mais que le crâne il est très
très loin de très très loin d'atteindre
la taille de celui d'un tyrannosaure
globex aux russes ils n'étaient pas du
tout et là vous avez une estimation de
taille corporelle voilà de une tonne
donc l'estimation de taille corporelle
de une tonne d'une longueur estimée à 8
m si on part du principe que mlle bègue
zaurus était était proportionnée comme à
carcharodontosaures idée normal on va
dire bon bah ça c'est très on est encore
très très loin du t-rex qui faisait aux
alentours de 5 tonnes et est au maximum
douze à seize mètres de long en fonction
de comment vous le reconstituer quoi
donc donc d'où ça vient cette idée que
cette idée qu'on a un dinosaure qui
surpasse tyrannosaurus rex bas ça vient
en fait du fait que ou libéraux russes
étaient plus grands que les
tyrannosaures aux ide qui vivait à la
même époque que lui c'est écrit là dans
cette dernière phrase là c'est ce qu'il
ya d'écrit ici
où l'ouzbek zaurus était plus grand que
les tyrannosauridés contemporain et que
les carcharodontosaures idées sont
restés plus grand que les tyrannosaures
aux ide au moins jusqu'à la fin du
turonien
puis est venu
tyrannosaurus rex puis est venue tard
bozo russe bref puis sont venus les
vrais gros tyrannosauridés voilà les
ceux qui sont puissants voilà et qui ont
remplacé du coup les carcharodontosaures
et les cartes carcharodontosaures il est
arrivé donc donc c'est de là que ça
vient cette histoire qui a dinosaures
qui surpasse tyrannosaurus mais en
réalité non
ya pas de ty et à cesser ou le bec aux
russes ne surpasse absolument pas
tyrannosaurus ni en taille ni en
longueur ni en quoi que ce soit et il
n'a jamais croisé tyrannosaurus de toute
façon donc non
on sent bien une volonté de vouloir
surfer sur sur la vague jurassique world
3 d'ailleurs mais non non ça n'a rien à
voir ça a été survendue usa a été sûr
c'est plus que ça a été survendue ça a
été vendu sur une idée absolument
fausses voilà qu'une confusion
volontaire entre tyrannosaure enfin
quand on parle des tyrannosaures on
parle des tyrannosaures aux ide ou des
tyrannosauridés et quand on parle du
tyrannosaure on parle de tyrannosaurus
rex voilà donc c'est la confusion
semi volontaire entre tyrannosaure dans
le sens tyrannosauridés tyrannosaure
dans le sens tyrannosaurus rex mais non
cet article n'a jamais démontré
que ou de big lots russe était plus plus
grand que tyrannosaurus rex donc voilà
on reste dans les dinosaures avec une
découverte qui a été publié tout tout
tout récemment juste il ya quelques
jours au moment où j'enregistre et cette
découverte et bien c'est celle du
possible première en kilos d'or africain
il faut savoir qu'on n'a jamais
découvert dans kg d'or en afrique avant
ça il
ya d'ailleurs il ya qu un seul autre
ankylose or en dans le gondwana donc
dans l'hémisphère sud on va dire ça
comme ça
et il me semble que c'est en australie
qui a des ans qu'ils osent ans ils ont
quand même des ankylosante en australie
liamine me notamment comment qu'il use
or si je me rappelle bien en australie
mais bref les ankylose or c'est pas ça
prolifère pas voilà maintenant dans
l'hémisphère sud voilà c'est ça l'idée
et en afrique on en avait pas du tout on
avait incité go there on a dû stégosaure
en afrique enfin n'a pas incité goes on
a dû stégosaure en afrique on a
évidemment le ceux qui ont été
découverts à athènes d'un gourou 1 qui
sont qui sont très connus en afrique du
sud on avait aussi parentaux dont donc
on a quand même des stégosaure en
afrique on a dû tirer au fort mais on
n'avait pas d'un kilo d'or jusqu'à cette
découverte alors découverte qui consiste
en une côte que vous voyez là une cote
relativement gros seins quand même une
belle bête hein je viens donc cesser de
taille dinosaur yens j'ai envie de dire
et donc cette côte elle est recouverte
d'ostéo dern qui forme d'epic on voit
bien quand on voit les coupes
histologiques qui ont été faites dans la
côte on voit ici la limite entre l'os de
la côte en dessous et l'os de lost et au
derme au-dessus voyez cette limite elle
est là donc c'est ce qui a représenté
ici en trois dimensions voilà la côte et
l'ostéo dern donc s'il s'agit pas de
depping qui sont sur les côtes comme on
peut les avoir chez un psy nappe sitcom
protubérants sommes par exemple bien
chez un autre cynapsys bas comme comme
les semaines à condom ty et par exemple
qui ont des épines sur le sur les
valeurs là c'est plus sur les épines ne
râle mais bref c'est pas sur les côtes
mais bref voilà le l'idée c'est que
c'est pas des épines qui sont faites de
la côte ça vient pas de la côte ce sont
vraiment des ostéo d'herbe sur les côtes
est des trucs qui sont de taille
dinosaures yens
au jurassique et qui ont des os terreux
d'herbe bas ce sont ceux sont les tirer
aux forts et les ankylose or ils ont pas
d épines comme ça et les pardons les
stégosaures non pas des épines comme ça
apparemment eux ils d'identification
ankylose or donc et c'est plutôt
intéressant parce que justement comme je
le disais ça
ça amène ses deux premiers ankylose or
identifiés en afrique et étant donné que
la bestiole à 166 millions d'années
et qu'elle vient du parce qu'elle vient
du
jurassique moyen du maroc
donc ça nous amène voilà la limite
bâtonnier un calot vient ses 166
millions d'années à peu près à ça en
fait le plus vieil ankylose or connu
aussi ce qui ce qui peut être perturbant
mais qui ne l'est pas tant que ça
puisque on a aussi les premiers parmi
les premiers de roméo zoo rider au niger
qui sont représentés par des empreintes
de pas de voiliers de des empreintes de
pas à deux doigts donc
vers une origine africaine de plus en
plus de dinosaures point d'interrogation
d'origine africaine des dromes et aux
orres une origine africaine des enclos
dans ce serait vachement
ça vachement intéressant mais il ya
quand même des mecs qu'il faut souligner
et le 1er mai qui m'a été qui m'a été
proposé par
mon collègue et camarade séverin morel
salut c'est vrai je sais que tu regarde
cette vidéo donc donc c'est vrai morel
qui a très justement fait remarquer que
autant les ankylose or que les
stégosaures on n'a jamais retrouvé des
pin sur les côtes c'est à dire que les
chez les ankylose orb et toute façon ils
ont des enfants ils ont osé ostéo
d'armes absolument partout les ankylose
or mais ils sont pas localisés
spécifiquement sur les côtes là quand
même le enfin ça se voit bien sûr la
section l'alleud lost heroes d'herbe il
est sur la côte il est adapté à la côte
donc ça ça s'est jamais vu en tout cas
je suis plutôt d'accord c'est vrai que
c'est pas quelque chose qui est très
commun chez les 100 kg d'or et il le
remarque d'ailleurs voilà dans le choc
dans le paragraphe taxonomique identity
il le souligne aussi les auteurs font
remarquer que c'est vrai que globalement
c'est pas commun d'avoir une épine sur
une côte et donc donc c'est quand même
bizarre c'est quand même bizarre on
remarque aussi la forme de t de la
section de la côte qui se retrouve
effectivement chez les ankylose or mais
cette forme de t de la côte on la
retrouve aussi chez les tortues
et les tortues elle par contre elles
sont bien connus pour avoir des ostéo
derme sur leur cote puisque c'est leur
cote fusionnée qui forment la carapace
et donc les osthéos derme par dessus les
côtes finissent forme la couche externe
de la carapace donc la combinaison ostéo
derme surcôte
et les deux étant plus ou moins
fusionner c'est une combinaison qui
existe chez les tortues
et ça du coup je pense qu'ils auraient
dû passer quand même un poil plus de
temps pour pour essayer de nous
convaincre que c'était pas des tortues
ceci étant dit on est bien d'accord
qu'il s'agit d'une cote isolé comme ça
se voit très bien ici c'est une cote
isolé or par définition chez les tortues
les côtes sont fusionnés
on a des exemples de très vieille tortue
du permien et du trias qui ont des côtes
nom fusionné en forme de t en section
certes mais non fusionner mais ces
tortues là non pas d'ostéo derme et on a
des exemples de tortues qui ont des
ostéo derme sur leurs côtes mais ce sont
des tortues qui ont toutes les cotes
fusionner en carapace donc la
combinaison ostéo derme échos de
fusionner chez les tortues enfin la
combinaison ostéo derme plus qu'autre
nom fusionné chez les tortues
n'existe pas pour l'instant
du moins si on interprète cette chose là
comme un an philosophe la combinaison
ostéo derme plus qu'autre nom fusionné
n'existe pas chez les tortues et on
s'attend pas à trouver une tortue avec
des côtes nord fusionner au jurassique
la dernière tortue avec les côtes sont
fusionnés elle a vécu au trias
d'ailleurs il semble que c'est le trias
moyens si je me rappelle bien ou
peut-être le trias supérieur mais bref
ces 225 millions d'années quoi donc on
est on est quand même une soixantaine de
millions d'années plus vieux
plus de 60 millions d'années bref mais
j'ai pas envie de faire de maths
aujourd'hui mais bref on est bien avant
quand même le jurassique moyen donc
moi je dis affaire à suivre pour cette
côte est de toute façon il le souligne
bien dans leur identification
taxonomique donc dans ce paragraphe la
taxonomie cas l'identity cette dernière
partie notamment fait la liste de tous
les autres candidats possibles donc il
ya évidemment les a et aux ors et les
philosophes qui ont aussi des ostéo
d'air mais qui normalement disparaissent
à la fin du trias donc on devrait pas
les retrouver il ya les titanosaures qui
ont aussi des ostéo derme mais
normalement ils apparaissent plus tard
notamment on les retrouve surtout au
crétacé donc les titanosaures c'est pas
et puis ils ont pas aller ils n'ont pas
l'heur ostéo d'armes particulièrement
localisés sur les côtes non plus donc
j'ai envie de dire soi soit on crée une
énorme ligne et fantômes en identifiant
ça comme une tortue avec des cotons
fusionner ou un ipod ou un philosophe
puisque tout ça c'est des trucs qui
disparaissent au trias les tortues lcos
de fusée les tortues à côte non
fusionner les uns et aux autres les
philosophes tout ça c'est des trucs qui
disparaissent à la fin du trias donc il
faut créer une énorme ligne et fantômes
pour les amener au jurassique
soit on crée une ligne et fantômes de
titanosaures en les étendant jusqu au
milieu du jurassique alors que
normalement c'est que crétacé ou voir
jurassique supérieur je suis pas sûr
pour les les titanosaures mais bref
voyez tous ces possibles candidats là
tous ces possibles candidats là il
impose la création d'une ligne et
fantômes dont j'ai envie de dire
l'identification comme un
comme un an qu'ils osent or en fait
c'est c'est la ligne de moindre
résistance j'ai envie de dire c'est
l'hypothèse la moins coûteuse parce
qu'on s'attend à trouver quand même des
ankylose or au jurassique moyen même si
les plus vieux ankylose ans il me semble
apparaissent au crétacé voir à la fin du
jurassique
on a quand même des tirs et au fort il
me semble que c'est céline aux eaux
russes on a quand même des tirs et au
fort avant ça donc on a quand même
on a quand même à gap entre les premiers
tirs et au fort et les premiers en
philosophe qui peut être rempli par des
enclos szohr tels que c'est elle que ce
nouveau ces nouvelles ankylose or
représenté par cette côte donc voila et
son petit nom j'ai oublié de dire son
petit nom cespi comme élu ça fait voilà
fait lorsque vous voulez ce pico mais
luce affaire est team au logis donc ce
pic us qui vient de spike enfin qui est
qui
qui veut dire épine quoi mais lui ce qui
veut dire collier et où cole et à faire
donc qui veut dire qui vient d'afrique
donc voilà c'est la petite épine le
collier des pin d'afrique
ça fait très biblique non vous trouvez
pas la couronne d'épinés d'afrique bref
spi comme il s'affaire donc très très
intéressante aimait à suivre je pense
affaire à suivre parce que le
ce serait vraiment un an qu'ils osent or
très bizarre mais quoi qu'il en soit
enfin je veux dire quelle que soit
l'identité de spie comme élu ce que ce
soit une tortue anna est aux ordres
philosophe titanosaures ou n'importe
quel autre archosaures avec des ostéo
d'herbe de l'époque un crocodile je veux
dire par exemple quelle que soit
l'identité de spie comenius c'est du
blizzard
donc et comme je le disais le
l'identification comme un an qu'ils
osent ans c'est la moins bizarre de tout
voilà mais ça reste bizarre c'est la
ligne comme je le disais c'est vraiment
le l'identification de moins de
résistance
on reste en afrique avec les dinosaures
africains et notamment la des plus
célèbres dinosaures sud africain et
héros dont deux aux russes petit
dinosaure en et y tient en et ischia des
tout premiers dinosaures en estie ce qui
était redouté aux russes qui tient son
nom du fait que justement il a des
canines donc il a une dentition et héros
dont tu voyais et dentition les canines
sont différentes des incisives qui sont
différentes des pascaline donc c'est de
là que vient son nom était redouté aux
russes découvert dans le jurassique
inférieur d'afrique du sud et donc ça
c'est là cette étude
publiée par mes collègues de
l'université du vibrateur strand victor
jaune à kimberley jonah que vous avez
vues dont j'ai parlé la dernière fois
dans le dans une de mes dans la récente
vidéo sur le déclin des dinosaures donc
cet été aux dons aux orris il a été
scanné à grenoble au synchrotron de
grenoble donc une étude qui fait
intervenir à la fois de la recherche
française et sud-africaines donc je peux
me sentir concernée cette
étude la cellule de la première étude du
squelette complet des terreaux d'auto
aux russes et qui propose notamment à
une théorie pour expliquer pourquoi les
ornithischiens en fait on
on un prêt pubis est ce que vous savez
que les ornithischiens donc vous avez la
division sacro-sainte j'ai envie de dire
des dinosaures entre les sons risquer à
les ornithischiens bon division qui a
été comme je lui dis remise en question
récemment
par bach aux étals mais enfin ça reste
une division anatomique importantes
entre les dinosaures à bassin de
reptiles ou le vouvoyer le pubis est
orienté vers l'avant et les dinosaures à
bassin d'oiseaux les ornithischiens où
le public s'est orienté vers l'arrière
et donc ça ça reste un grand mystère et
l'oncle et pourquoi pourquoi cette
division pourquoi ce changement soudain
de morphologie du bassin et bien victor
et les collègues
de d'afrique du sud propose la théorie
qu'en fait c'est lié à la respiration
c'est lié à la respiration notamment
parce que les ornithischiens voyait la
plupart des ordis titien n'ont pas ces
petits au convent trop ses côtes
ventrale qu'on appelle legast rallye
aucun artiste y en a deux gars stralis
sauf et héros dont aux eaux russes était
remonté aux russes comme vous pouvez le
voir sur les images précédentes il a des
gars stralis est le seul en fait à
combiner la morphologie bassin dernier
titien plus gast rallier alors il a des
gars strahl y est il a des espèces de
plaques bizarre en plus des castrats lit
donc c'est ça on fait vraiment un animal
très très très curieux et voilà le voilà
legast rallye de l'été rando taurus donc
c'est le seul en éthiciens qui combine à
la fois des castrats lits et un bassin
ornithischiens et donc c'est un
intermédiaire en fait un entre les deux
morphologie la morphologie de base sort
ischia bassins sont risqués à gastes
rallye et la morphologie dérivés bassin
ornithischiens pas de gastes rallye donc
et airs d'autoroute il combine les deux
il combine à la fois bassin en éthiciens
egast rallye et donc les collègues font
l'hypothèse que ça c'est lié à des
changements respiratoire en fait
notamment avec l'apparition d'un muscle
qui s'appelle le ppm alors je ne suis
pas complètement sûr de comment on
traduit ça le plus beau péritonéale
voilà donc le muscle plus beaux
péritonéale qui comme son nom l'indiqué
est relié au pubis d'un côté aux
péritoine de l'autre et donc permet
l'extension et la compression des des
poumons voilà donc les ornithischiens
aurait eu un appareil respiratoire très
spécifique très spéciale avec ce muscle
plus beaux péritonéale accroché au
processus pré pubiens
delà de leur bassin en it is tient et se
et c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient un
bassin en et ischia en fait et ça et ça
c'est très intéressant parce qu'en fait
ça permet vous voyez cette énorme espace
que ça libère la voyez que là vous avez
legast rallye qui occupent cet espace là
et vous avez le pubis ici qui occupent
cet espace si et chez les ornithischiens
si vous regardez sans legast rallye et
sans le pubis orienté vers l'avant vous
avez cette énorme espace vide et cet
énorme espace vide bah c'est pas de
l'espace vide en réalité c'est le
digestif et oui les ornithischiens sont
des animaux herbivores essentiellement
voire même quasi exclusivement je crois
qu'il ya qu un seul en it is canon qu'on
suppose être carnivores c'est un an
qu'ils osent or
200 kg d'or du vietnam je crois ou du
laos je sais plus bref je m'égare mais
le voilà les ornithischiens étant
essentiellement herbivores voire quasi
exclusivement herbivores ils ont besoin
d'un énorme tube digestif pour fermenté
leur nourriture sont pas des ruminants
les indices qui est ce son ce sont des
animaux qui en avaient besoin d'un tube
digestif gigantesque pour faire monter
leur nourriture pour pouvoir casser les
fibres de cellulose qui sont extrêmement
difficile à digérer et du coup pour
libérer en fait ces finalistes ce que je
dis mais évidemment pour ne le
comprenais pas dans le sens mines alice
mais évidemment le set ce système
respiratoire en fait optimise l'espace
dans la cavité abdominale
permettant
permettant l'expansion
d'un tube digestif gigantesque afin de
digérer la nourriture plus efficacement
la nourriture végétale plus efficacement
voilà
et ça c'est quand même une belle théorie
je trouve très intéressante est donc
interdite aux russes est un taxon c'est
un chaînon manquant voilà je n'hésite
pas à employer le mot entre la condition
souricière est la condition en it is
tienne
voilà donc ça c'est une très belle
découverte très belle et c'est un très
bel article vous voyez très bien
illustré victor est un très très bon
toutes les illustrations là que vous
voyez les dessins sont faits par victor
qui est un très très bon palet aux
artistes aussi donc voilà très très
belles études je vous dont je vous
recommande la lecture puisque c'est
publié dans life et que i live est
totalement open access alors un article
qui m'a un peu fait rire qui a fait rire
beaucoup de monde
qui est parue dans le journal of iberian
geology qu'un petit journal espagnol
voilà de géologie et alors c'est un
article qui est intéressant parce que
c'est vraiment le sait vraiment un
article assez symptomatique de la
science de la science faucher pendant le
coc vide c'est à dire que c'est des gens
qui ont scanné des jouets des jouets
dinosaures et qui à partir de ces jeux
des scan 3d de ces jouets dinosaures en
fait on estimé le volume des jouets les
ont remis à l'échelle pour estimer la
masse corporelle des dinosaures
correspondant voilà ce que vous voyez là
body mass et donc ils discutent la
reconstitution des masse corporelle des
dinosaures c'est vraiment l'exemple
typique de sciences faucher pendant le
coc vie de quoi
ces voix là elle même elle s'est juste
pour nous montrer que même les
scientifiques la science a été affecté
par le cos vide la paléontologie
notamment nous qui ne pouvons pas
directement
contribué là encore que j'avais parlé
d'un article où il disait que justement
il ya des analyses génétiques de des
gènes de néandertal qui avait montré que
justement il ya certains gènes de
sensibilité au co vide qui nous viennent
de néandertal
donc la paléontologie peut contribuer à
la recherche sur le co vide mais c'est
vrai que quand on travaille sur les
dinosaures on a du mal voilà et que tout
l'argent et siphonné direction recherche
sur le vide on a un peu du mal
là ça ressemble c'est typiquement de la
science de confinement vous voyez
bon je me moque pas je veux dire on a
tous on a tous fait ça on a tous fait
cela c'est de la science de confinement
on fait ce qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a on
n'a pas le droit de sortir bas qu'est ce
qu'on fait mais on a son petit appareil
pour numériser les figurines vous voyez
c'est vraiment un appareil de poche et
puis on le relier au laptop enfin un
ordi portable et puis on fait ce qu'on
peut
c'est très voilé assez débrouillard
c'est de la débrouille exactement on
retourne quand même à vers un peu plus
de science sérieuses avec le dernier
article de christophe hendrix dont il
nous avait déjà annoncé la publication
la dernière fois qu'on l'avait
interviewée rappelez-vous christophe
hendrix il nous avait parlé du cloaque
du cloaque de
sita cause or si je me rappelle bien et
donc il continue à étudier la peau des
dinosaures et donc il l'a publié
maintenant la peau de
carcharodontosaures russie un dépôt
spécimens de carcassonne motoriste qui
ont été découverts il de la peau je m'en
vais directement aux figures voyez
très très belle préservation de la peau
chez ces carcharodontosaures us on voit
bien les écailles et bâle ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec ça c'est que c'est
surtout des écailles en fait il n'ya pas
de plumes chez carcharodontosaures us
chez carnotaurus pardon jeudi car 40
autobus et carnotaurus excusez moi donc
il ya ces carnotaurus et donc
carnotaurus pas comme vous voyez il
était surtout recouvert des cas ils vont
ce qui n'est pas une grosse surprise
c'est un à belize au rider donc les
abbés lisons idées sont très bazoches et
les théropodes mais ça n'est pas sans
rappeler
l'étude qui avait été faite de la peau
de des fragments de peau de
tyrannosauridés publié en 2017 qui avait
conclut aussi que les tyrannosaures idée
était complètement recouvert voiliers de
dca ya donc et puis bal hypothèses
restent toujours que de par leur grande
taille
plusieurs tonnes au moins les grands
théropodes n'avez pas besoin d'avoir de
plume pour conserver leur chaleur dont
ils étaient globalement recouvert des
cayes et non pas de plumes
la question a été posée est-ce qu'il
muets comme des serpents
la réponse est probablement non puisque
les arcs aux ordres ne mue pas enfin je
veux dire les les pas dire les arts
causant parce que les oiseaux il m'eut
mais ils perdent leur plume
individuellement je veux dire même si
ils perdent leur plume plus ou moins en
même temps selon les espèces
leur plume se perdent individuellement
et les crocodiles par contre il ne mue
pas donc les archosaures ne mue pas donc
non les dires et très peu de chances si
vous vous baladiez au crétacé voilà il
ya très peu de chances que vous tombiez
sur une
2 car nos torts de ou de tyrannosaure
on se déplace vers les oiseaux
maintenant on monte un petit peu dans la
phylogénie vers les oiseaux où on
s'arrête sur cette étude du cerveau
dictée ornis ils ternissent la fameuse
oiseaux marins le fameux oiseaux marins
du crétacé avec des dents très connu
haïti ornis l'un des plus connus l'un
des oiseaux à dans les plus connus et
donc le cerveau de haïti ornis basse et
cette étude csa montre que et ternissent
avait un cerveau d'oiseaux à ses proches
des oiseaux modernes au final vous voyez
ici de comparaison entre
un oiseau modernes ici voilà et vous
voyez le cerveau dit ti ornis ici vous
voyez que c'est juste les hémisphères
qui sont un peu moins développés qui
vont pas jusqu'à toucher le cervelet qui
est ici voyez là chez les oiseaux
modernes vous avez les hémisphères qui
sont tellement développé que là vous
avez directement contact avec le
cervelet cervelet qui a eu lui aussi
très développés puisque c'est la
coordination des mouvements et quand on
est un animal volant c'est quand même
mieux d'avoir une énorme coordination
des mouvements et du coup vous avez les
lobes optiques qui sont eux aussi très
très développée chez les oiseaux qui ont
bougé sur le côté puisqu'ils ont été
poussés en fait sur le côté par le
contact entre les hémisphères
du cerveau et cérébraux et donc ici
ornis lui il n'a pas encore ce contact
voyez que les lobes optiques sont encore
les lobes optiques sait pas encore c'est
par encore le sert et le cervelet du
cerveau lui même
donc c'est la différence majeure est
donc ce que cette étude
nous apprend essentiellement c'est que
le petit titilleur ecti ornis qu'ils ont
étudiés possède ce qu'ils appellent un
bouliste là c'est ce mot ici le bouliste
et le moule stress qui deviendra
l'équivalent du néocortex chez les
oiseaux modernes
ce qui est important puisque le
néocortex les fonctions cognitives
supérieures comme on aimait les appelait
il ya eu il ya 50 ans donc les
l'intelligence voilà la fameuse
intelligence que l'intelligent le moins
intelligent c'est très intéressant
puisque quand on le dit tout le monde
sait de quoi on parle quand on essaye de
le définir plus personne ne sait de quoi
on parle mais bref l'intelligence la
fameuse intelligence produite par le
néocortex et dans ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est qu'en fait les les
dinosaures et archaeopteryx d'ailleurs
je crois non pas de boules ce tu as les
dinosaures non aviens
archéoptéryx incluent non pas de goult
donc ils n'ont pas de trace de néocortex
ce qui veut dire que le néocortex des
mammifères et le neocortex des oiseaux
sont deux choses totalement
indépendantes qui ont évolué de façon
totalement convergente
ce qui est pas surprenant quand on sait
la nature
au niveau cellulaire je veux dire quand
on compare les neurones du moule sts des
oiseaux modernes aux néo cortex des
mammifères on voit que c'est
complètement organisé de façon
différente voilà donc c'est pas étonnant
d'apprendre que ces deux choses
totalement différentes ont évolué de
façon totalement indépendante
même si le résultat final est
globalement comparables donc c'est
intéressant et alors si l autre chose
qui est intéressante avec cette étude
c'est qu'elle pareil ça a été survendue
vous avez probablement entendu parler
alors je ne sais plus quand ça a été
publié donc ça a été publiée dans sa
gamme 7,26 sûr qu'une succursale du
prestigieux journal science isles ça a
été publié le 30 juillet donc aux
alentours du mois d'août vous avez dû
entendre parler de vous avez dû voir
passer des titres du genre
comment c'était
les aurons c'est pourquoi les oiseaux
ont survécu à l'extinction
qui a tué les dinosaures un truc comme
ça l'est pourquoi les oiseaux ont
survécu et pas les dinosaures voilà vous
avez dû voir passer ça ça n'a rien à
voir
ces gens vous avez vu passer des titres
plus ta clique qui renvoyait à cet
article la enfin si le si l'auteur si la
politique du journal consiste à quand
même mettre un petit lien qui renvoie à
la source vous avez vu ce lien vous
diriger vers cet article là dans un
article qui parlait de l'extinction
crétacé tertiaire
et qui vous disaient on sait pourquoi
les oiseaux ont survécu et pas les
dinosaures et non
mais non pas du tout enfin je viens
enfin si oui il fasse on voit quand même
dans le titre là qu'il ya une tentative
de survente en mode extinction crétacé
tertiaire mais
en fait non c'est juste un article de
paléo neurologie c'est à dire que oui
les oiseaux avaient un néo cortex dès la
fin du crétacé voilà c'est ça c'est
juste ça est-ce que ça a eu un rapport
avec leur survie la crise
crétacé-tertiaire bah je sais pas vous
avez vu indique-t-il ornis quelque part
vous
moi non j'ai prévu de dict ironise donc
hilti ornis malgré tout ça tout ça
présence de néocortex n'a pas survécu à
la l'extinction crétacé-tertiaire donc
je vois pas je vois pas le rapport il
dit qu'il voit pas le rapport bref
voilà on profite qu on parle de moulage
endocriniens et de l'étude du cerveau
des espèces fossiles pour glisser
lentement mais sûrement vers les manifs
r on va quand même parler de
manifestants ce paléo news avec l'étude
du moulage endocrinien de 1,10 us dirigé
par maeva aurillac donc une étude franco
américaine par cette chercheuse de
l'université de montpellier et donc
c'est l'étude du cerveau de 1,10 us 1 de
husky et dont vous voyez le crâne ici
qui est connu pour être je vais jose
employer le mot le chaînon manquant
entre les arts cieux dactyle et les
cétacés donc j'ai fait une vidéo encore
très récemment pour expliquer justement
cette transition des arceaux d'actine
jusqu aux cétacés les cétacés donc la
génétique nous indique que les cétacés
donc les dauphins et les baleines sont
proches parents des arts cieux dactyle à
savoir les vaches les cochons les
chameaux et les hippopotames donc
notamment ils sont les cétacés sont très
proches des hippopotames
donc c'est bon c'est pas si étonnant que
ça je veux dire les hippopotames sont
semi aquatique donc sait pas non plus si
c'est si étonnant que ça le truc c'est
que les cétacés sont globalement
carnivores alors que les architectes ils
sont globalement herbivores donc c'est
quand même assez étonnant de voir les
cétacés ont trouvé leurs racines
évolutive au sein des ars yeux d'actes
il est donc un dossier us fait pas ed si
on veut l'ars you dactyle c'est parce
qu'en général ça 1,2 illustre semble en
général à un martiaux d'acted il à
quatre pattes il est herbivore ya pas de
doute là dessus mais il a des détails
anatomiques
notamment de l'oreille interne et de
l'oreille en général qui en font
définitivement un
qui en font définitivement un proche
parent des cétacés alors il me semble
d'ailleurs qu'on en voit on voit très
bien de ces détails anatomiques
justement dans une des sections en 3d
décès de section en rayons x voilà vous
voyez ici l'oreille c'est la bulle
tympanique dinde aux innus ici et vous
voyez que sept bulletins panique elle
est incroyablement épaisse là on la voit
on voit l'autre bulletin panique de
l'autre côté puisque évidemment il y en
a deux donc là bulletin panique c'est la
caisse de résonance qui attachés à
l'oreille et qui est accroché au tympan
comme son nom l'indiqué est donc sept
bulletins panique elle est
incroyablement épaisse chez un ado et
russe ce qui est un caractère de cétacés
c'est une adaptation à l'audition à
l'audition en milieu semi aquatique
enfin en milieu aquatique pardon donc et
elle dispose de ce qu'on appelle un
volume chrome c'est cet épaississement
côté interne de la bulletin panique donc
l'un vaut luc rome c'est aussi un
caractère typique de cétacés donc bref
c'est pas ça le but de l'article but de
l'article c'est d'étudier le cerveau est
justement un dos et lucie là aussi c'est
un autre caractère du cerveau qui est
intermédiaire entre les arceaux dactyle
que vous voyez ici donc les hippos les
vaches et les autres à ceux d'actifs
bazot voyez que les
lobes olfactif ici chez ces arceaux
d'actes ils sont très court comparé à la
taille du cerveau général alors que chez
les cétacés comme ici par exemple ce
mois-ci remington hausse et husky à des
cétacés un des premiers cétacés qui a
vécu il me semble court de l'éocène
voyez que là par contre les lobes half
actifs sont très très allongée
probablement probablement parce que ben
en fait les lobes wolf actifs dégénère
petit à petit en fait chez les ch et les
cétacés
la position de la boîte crânienne aussi
changes chez cétacés la boîte crânienne
va se positionner plus à l'arrière du
crâne le museau s'allongent et les lobes
lf active des jeunes et donc les lobes
half actifs bas ça sert à rien de
renifler sous l'eau quand on est un
mammifère ça ne marche pas tout
simplement les les poissons peuvent
renifler sous l'eau parce qu'ils ont des
coen externe ils ont une double paire de
cohen externe donc ils ont des le nez en
fête s'ouvre à l'extérieur et part vers
l'intérieur mais repart vers l'extérieur
ensuite donc en fait voilà c'est comme
ça qui renifle nous si on essaye de
renifler comme ça on avale de l'eau
parce que nos cohen nos colonnes donc
nos narines s'ouvre à l'extérieur mais
ensuite elle s'ouvre à l'intérieur donc
si on essaye de renifler sous l'eau en
aval de l'eau quoi vous avez déjà essayé
de renifler de la flotte vous étouffez
voilà ça marche pas donc
donc on ne peut pas en tant que
mammifères renifler sous l'eau voilà
tout simplement on peut par contre on
peut remplacer le sens de l'odorat par
le sens du goût par exemple ça marche
très bien un organe qui s'appelle
l'organe voméronasal qui permet de
remplacer ce ça par exemple mais bref je
m'égare le fait est que les lobes
olfactif du fait qu'on ne peut pas
renifler sous l'eau en tant que
mammifères dégénère chez quasiment tous
les mammifères marins
chez les siréniens par exemple ils ont
quasiment plus du tout de l'homme wolf
actifs est les cétacés et donc pareil
ils ont plus de loeb l'oeuf actifs les
pinnipèdes
les lobes olfactives sont très réduits
notamment chez les phoques et chez les
morts ce qui n'ont pas non plus de leur
bulle factice en tout cas ils sont très
très petit chez les morses donc bref
c'était un caractère général des espèces
qui s'adapte à la vie aquatique est donc
un do in us dont le cerveau a été étudié
par maeva orliac et tennyson 1,10 us est
dans un état intermédiaire c'est-à-dire
que son cerveau commence à bouger vers
l'arrière plus il est plus vers
l'arrière que chez les
que chez les autres arts se date il est
chez un de plus on a aussi un début
d'allongement des lobes lf actifs ce qui
veut pas forcément dire que son sens de
l'odorat était moins développés je veux
dire on tout ce qu'on a c'est la taille
des lobes olfactif donc on peut pas
vraiment dire si la wolf actifs étaient
très très efficaces ou pas chez un
dollar us mais en tout cas il ya un
début d'allongement de ses lobs
effectifs chez un deuil ou ce qui est
intermédiaire voilà entre les cétacés
comme remington au site us et leurs plus
proches parents hippopotames bien
comme les hippopotames moderne donc
voilà à nouveau caractère j'ai envie de
dire qu'ils placent un deuil ou à la
marge entre cétacés et a reçus au
tactile et qui démontre une bonne fois
pour toutes j'ai envie de dire s'il y
avait encore des doutes voilà ça
démontre une bonne fois pour toutes que
1,10 us est définitivement intermédiaire
entre cétacés et parce dactyle on reste
avec les mammifères avec cette nouvelle
étude de des gènes enfin une nouvelle
étude paléogénétique en l'occurrence du
palais au collagène s'est pas vraiment
de la génétique mais des gens ont réussi
des chercheurs donc essentiellement
de l'université de manchester
mais aussi collaboration espagnol voilà
qui ont donc une recherche européenne
ont réussi à extraire des des séquences
de collagène d'un gong fu terre
sud-américaine donc les gonfo terre ce
sont ces tu
sais ce qu'on appelait autrefois les
mastodontes
donc ce sont des gros des gros
proboscidiens qui vivait aux alentours
du miocène et du pliocène et qui sont
intermédiaires en fait entre les tout
premiers pauvres si bien qu'ils
n'avaient pas trompés et les éléphants
moderne et donc ils ont étudié le
collagène venant de ce mastodonte qui
s'appelle no piot mastodonte
augmentant ainsi la quantité de de
collagène anciens qu'on a pour ces
anciens proboscidiens rappelez vous on a
évidemment des codes séquences
génétiques pour mammuth on a réussi à
extraire du collagène et des séquences
génétiques pour mammuth qui est le
mastodonte américain et on a maintenant
donc des séquences de collagène pour un
nouveau un nouveau proboscidiens notions
mastodonte et alors ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec cet arbre
phylogénétique qu'ils ont et cher en
conservant la évidemment vous avez
l'arbre en version indigeste et ici vous
avez l'arbre en version digest donc on
va rester sur l'arbre en version digest
est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant donc c'est
que notions mastodonte et bien au lieu
d'avoir au lieu d'aller se brancher avec
les éléphants parce qu'on s'attend à ce
que nokia mastodonte en tant que goffaux
terre on s'attend à ce que nos tuyaux
mastodonte soit plus proche des et les
formes modernes qu'il ne l'ait du
mastodonte américain le mastodonte
américain c'est vraiment un truc qui a
divergé très tôt et elle est allée faire
son histoire dans son coin du moins le
croyait ton parce que bah du coup nos
tuyaux mastodonte ces séquences de
collagène au lieu d'indiquer que mammut
hommes et le mammouth à mais le
mastodonte américain pardon a fait son
histoire dans son coin bas notions basso
dont semblent indiquer que ben non en
fait
apparemment ce mastodonte sud-américains
qui est notée au mastodonte serait plus
proche parent de du mastodonte américain
qu'il le lait des éléphantes idée
qui est contraire à sa classification en
tant que goffin terre voilà parce que
nos tuyaux mastodonte était considéré
comme un gros flotteurs et ça ça a des
implications assez majeur en termes de
biogéographie si jamais on
si jamais ce résultat se confirme ça a
des implications majeures en termes de
biogéographie parce que si le mammouth à
mais le mastodonte pardon américain
c'est pas ma faute il s'appelle mammites
je dirais s'appelle ma muté c'est un
mastodonte
c'est pas évident
bref si jamais noté au mastodonte donc
un proboscidiens sud américain est plus
proche parent du mastodonte nord
américain bah on parle d'une dispersion
qui on parle d'un événement
biogéographique mineurs c'est à dire des
proboscidiens nord-américain qui ceux
qui vont conquérir l'amérique du sud
bon c'était au pliocène à ça c'était il
ya un moment déjà il ya plus de plus
d'éléphants en amérique du sud depuis
longtemps évidemment mais y en a eu
c'est quand même intéressant de savoir
qu'il ya eu des éléphants l'amérique du
sud et
donc voilà si nous tuons mastodonte est
proche parent du mastodonte américain ça
veut dire qu'on est sur un événement de
dispersion à ces mineurs en fait alors
que
nos tuyaux mastodonte étant jusqu'à
présent considéré comme un gros feu
terre on s'imaginait qu'en fait légaux
faut taire ils sont originaires
d'afrique il y en a pas mal qui sont
originaires d'asie mais bref on
s'imaginait un événement de dispersion
qui venaient d'asie et qui passait par
l'amérique du nord et qui auraient
atteint l'amérique du sud donc là en
considérant notions mastodonte comme un
gros font taire on avait un événement de
dispersion majeur intercontinental quoi
donc là on ces deux histoires
complètement différente en fait et donc
d'avoir déplacé nos tuyaux mastodonte
d'ego faut taire au mastodonte
américain ça change complètement
l'histoire de notions mastodonte donc
c'est quand même une découverte très
intéressante et on a hâte de connaître
la suite on espère qu'on va découvert
encore plus de collagène de
c2c proboscidiens anciens parce que les
proboscidiens c'est quand même la classe
et on transition en transition sans
transition vers des études françaises
bon si on a eu tout à l'heure d'études
de maeva orliac qui était à moitié
française l'étude je veux dire aux
ivoiriens est française mais l'étude
était à moitié française donc là on
transition vers des études de franco
française avec la description d'un
nouveau squelette complet d'un alors ils
appellent ça un requin mais ce n'est pas
vraiment un requin c'est un eczéma quand
ils forment donc c'est pas encore des
requins on va dire qui vient de du
massif central voilà un nouveau un
nouveau conte driss y un nouveau poisson
cartilagineux du massif central et vous
allez voir le squelette est absolument
merveilleux regarder ça c'est un
squelette tout à fait complet avec
l'envoi les vertèbres ici on voit les
nageoires ici on voit le crâne ici et
donc le set à glénac anti forme parce
que il possède cette épine à l'arrière
de la tête voilà que vous voyez très
très bien ici sur le fossile donc
magnifique fossiles de xénophon zinc
anti forme de france qui nous prouve
s'il si vous en doutiez encore que on a
un très très beau registre fossile en
france encore faut-il encore faut-il
qu'ils aient des trous suffisamment gros
pour y avoir accès parce que le problème
en france c'est que on a un sol très
fertile est très épais qui recouvre non
fossiles autre étude française dont vous
avez très certainement entendu parler
c'est la fameuse étude condamine étale
sur le déclin des dinosaures avant la
limite crétacé tertiaire
études dont j'ai déjà parlé dans une
autre vidéo j'ai essayé de vous mettre
une petite vignette là pour que vous
puissiez aller la voir j'ai déjà parlé
en et au large de cette vidéo de cette
étude étude qui a maquillé al'avantage
comme je disais de relancer un débat qui
avait un peu tendance à mourir dans la
littérature bien que comme je lé précisé
dans l'autre vidéo il y avait des
publications encore en 2012 sur le sujet
mais bref
il ya peu il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
tendance à enterrer complètement le
déclin des dinosaures parce que
justement il ya cette histoire de
météorites et que pour beaucoup de gens
la météorite bas c'est forcément une
extinction rapide
or cela n'exclut pas l'autre on est
c'est pas parce qu'une météorite qui
avait prévu un d'éclat avant ait eu
apparemment avec le modèle qu'ils
utilisent avec les données qu'ils
utilisent ils trouvent qu'il y à un
déclin voilà donc le déclin qui est bien
représentée ici vous voyez là toutes ces
pentes qui descendent
et toutes ces belles pentes en descente
que vous voyez ici c'est une étude qui
est pas de qui est par exemple de
défauts notamment qu'ils ont utilisés
essentiellement du gros dinosaures
qu'ils ont exclu pas mal de données mais
on est bien d'accord que je veux dire
tout toutes les études qui utilisent des
modèles de toutes façons font des
hypothèses de base qui sont discutables
et qui sont évidemment discuter donc on
verra c'est pareil on verra la suite il
y aura certainement des réponses à cette
étude qui seront publiés un jour
mais comme j'ai dis j'en discute déjà
dans une autre vidéo dont je vais pas
m'arrêter trop longtemps dessus on
termine encore avec une étude française
de la sorbonne
qui a trouvé un lien intéressant entre
variations du niveau des mers donc les
vallées variations très statique et les
extinctions de masse
c'est une étude essentiellement
géologique et les variations de la mer
qui enregistre enfin les variations du
niveau statique et donc les variations
climatiques qui vont avec qui il
enregistre alors ils trouvent une
corrélation qui est significative
non bon jeu je suis d'un jeu j'ai pas le
bagage scientifique je vous avoue pour
comprendre ce genre d'étude mais je
tenais à mentionner quand même que cette
étude existe mais je vous avoue que j'ai
pas ce qu'il faut pour les comprendre
pour comprendre une étude comme ça ça
implique vous voyez ça implique des
graphes de la géologie une compréhension
des isotopes une compréhension des
modélisations qui ont été utilisés que
je n'ai pas donc en toute humilité je
rapporte juste le fait que c'était une
existe t'il trouve apparemment une
corrélation entre extinction de masse et
variations du niveau marin et donc du
climat
et et évidemment les haies et que ça des
implications du coup pour la
paléontologie ceci étant dit moi quand
je regarde ses courbes je vois pas de
lien évident avec les extinctions de
masse mais bon comme je les dis je n'ai
pas le bagage qu'il faut pour comprendre
à fond et pour avoir un avis critique
efficace on va dire de ce genre d'étude
mais voilà je tenais quand même a
mentionné que cette étude ait existé et
que si quelqu'un si l'un des auteurs a
envie de venir en parler ben je suis
plus couverts je suis plus couverts à 7
cette possibilité voilà j'étais paléo
news je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
rien manquer anciens
dis à très bientôt
[Musique]